there's a lot of like changes come out
of oakland but yeah it was it was rough
and i'm a little asian girl
you know and i don't take any [ __ ]
because also it's not just from being
open that i'm tough i'm also a refugee
you know vietnamese refugee you put that
together there's like no feelings at
home like what's a feeling
like there's no feelings at home and
then when you go to i actually think
it was being asian and immigrant that
made me tougher
because that i would like we came from
vietnam you know and i would go even in
the projects they'd be like
complaining i'm like yo you get food
stamps and air conditioning
i came from a [ __ ] village like you
know
this is this is there was there was this
rapper the sudanese rapper named bangs
the funniest guy i think he's he's to
him he's a serious friend
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast
we have a very very special guest
hailing all the way from oceanside
california now i know a lot of you guys
have been wanting me to get
some professional fighters in here and
guess what
we have killer bee nguyen not only a
professional fighter
a [ __ ] vietnamese vietnamese
professional fighter no man [ __ ]
this is nuts what's up so
i actually found out about you uh-huh
because i only
i only started watching 1fc not too long
ago so honestly i started watching
probably
it was actually around the time when
they did the ben askren flip because
i've always been mighty miles too
exactly so i've only heard of one fc
every now and then but because i grew up
watching ufc and then
bellator i wasn't that big of a fan of
um
but yeah then i started watching 1fc
since then i had no idea
the the competitive level that yfc was
on
yeah because nobody was really talking
about it i think people in asia knew
what's up
yeah but over here nobody did and
specifically when it comes to
your guys's like bantamweights and
featherweights the [ __ ]
it's stacked it's sick it's unreal
yeah it's crazy just watching the the
level of striking
out there is amazing because i didn't
know also to want to see held out uh
kickboxing matches too so it's it's just
weird songs super fights yeah so i don't
understand how
how that company works so yeah i thought
it was just mma
no it's sick yeah and then we're
watching um
what's his name the dude that knocked
out uh stage northcutt and almost killed
him oh cosmo alexander that's my homie
dude cosmo is dope
when they when they matched up uh stage
with cosmo i was like what the [ __ ] is
going on
yeah you know in asia they don't do you
favors they just like
they don't they just match you up
because you know when you go to asia
especially thailand the
the uh mentality of fighting is you just
show up and fight like you just fight
they fight like every two weeks in
thailand you know
it's not like oh you don't pad your
record type of thing they just find you
whoever and they
you know match you up and if you say yes
you say yes
and sage northcutt said see
i was like because i know both of them
so i started mma
with sage and her sister at the same gym
we started mma together
oh what gym was that uh holger and i
don't even want to
promote his gym okay
i hate that gym in houston texas and um
uh yeah so anyway we started together so
i love them i love
those kids i love them i love sage um
but i also know cosmo i've known cosmo
for a long time and i was just like when
they were matched up i was like oh [ __ ]
that's a problem when people don't do
their research you know yeah
do you think sage northcutt did not know
the pedigree that [ __ ] cosplay
alexandra came from
he's amazing i think sage northcutt
trusts people and does what they
say so whoever on that team said that
said yes i don't know whom it was
but uh sage will you know sage is a good
kid
i would have i would have just looked at
that and been like hell [ __ ] no
that would have been the point where i
ran away from home yeah
you know what [ __ ] this i'm leaving i
mean just watching that number one
it's it's not a cage either like he's
gonna corner you and he's gonna knock
you out
i didn't know the difference i mean i've
fought in
rings before but i fought mma fighters
and rings when i fought stamp in a ring
i was like yo this is
crazy different so um yeah his brain i
mean i think the levels of striking was
just not
not a match i like who doesn't like
stage north cut as a person right
yeah but as a fighter he hasn't really
been tested and you put somebody
you put that man against him i mean what
did you think was gonna happen yeah
i didn't think he was getting knocked
out like that though
yeah i mean the thing is oh man it's
tough with karate like
i mean he does a good job but a lot of
karate people have to
adjust you know the only person i know
that does it so well is wonder boy and
he just freakishly
has like that iq yeah but like even my
good friend michelle waterson she
adjusts her she doesn't use much too
much of it you know
yeah because you keep your chin up and
you're bouncing and whatever
i don't know what game plan he had for
that but i knew like
cosmo was just gonna wait and that chin
was up in the air and that face was
relaxed
and he just hunted him down and he put
him to a corner he kept cutting him off
my god it was like a fiat getting hit by
a truck i remember watching it and then
my feet started sweating because i just
saw him start cornering him yeah and i'm
like what is this kid going to do
yeah and then lo and behold he broke his
orbital like he smashed his face
with one punch and cosmo felt bad after
too i talked to him afterwards
i mean cosmo's always been like he's so
sturdy
and durable um there's a couple of
fights i've seen him in and i've talked
to him afterwards where he was like man
i just wanted the decision because i
didn't want to like
break the person in half i i don't think
he meant to knock him out that hard i
think it's just a position you see sage
was moving
and while you're that's a problem with
bouncing and fighting
you got to be careful bouncing because
in mid bounce you have no
like like clinch like you have no like
you're not tightening
anything everything's loose and he got
hit mid mid midair
what do you think about that um what's
the fight he's the fighter that need
uh cyborg in the head he broke his
cranium yeah he's awesome that was
another one i was gonna say with cyborg
was
cyborg's one was cringey too but cyborg
i mean he's the og
yeah you know and he's done a lot of
things with sage it was like this was
his big
big new break at one and he's just so
young that hurt but um
i mean he hasn't been back since he
hasn't been back since i mean i don't
blame him yeah
yeah i mean but i i commend him for
trying to come back
because he has other options you know
yeah he's been to college like he has a
good
feature in other things but i guess he
just really his uh sister is also a 1fc
as well kobe
yeah i love coco i was like holy [ __ ]
the funny thing is i didn't know who she
was i was like
she looks like stage northcutt we used
to fight a legacy yeah we used to fight
a legacy together
and then she's actually married to uh
raymond
which is [ __ ] nuts but they met in
karate they're like karate legends
kobe and sage and obviously um her
husband
but they're like karate legends so
they've met a lot years ago in karate
tournaments
all across the world how's that there's
a couple that's the kick people's asses
all over the world [ __ ] nuts they're
sick and they're both tall and ripped
well how did how did you first of all
how did you get into
to mix martial arts in the first place
just because like i think
for me growing up i never saw first of
all the women that i hang around they
they weren't down scrapped like that's
not something
unless it was like hood scraps right
just going around pulling the hair
ripping out eyelashes and [ __ ] but i've
never met especially any of the
vietnamese homegirls i never met one
that wanted to go into a gym and fight
so how did you get involved in fighting
yo that's actually a misconception
because i grew up in the bay i grew up
in oakland hayward
san jose and like there's like whole
vietnamese gangs that like fight like
these girls throw down i remember
getting jumped by vietnamese girls
when i was in high school so vietnamese
vietnamese people are really feisty i
just think
that um yeah for sure i'm talking about
they would throw down but in terms of
like professional fighting yeah
it was more like because there's no
representation you know just like
anything it's like you know you don't
see
anybody out there doing it and then on
top of that our culture
clash is like crazy it's like you know
it's not really cute for us to fight but
um yeah i started as like self-defense i
just went to like a muay thai class
and i was like man i just got to do
something to make me feel like
stronger and better and whatever it's
going through some [ __ ] so
i went and then like i did really well
and then the coach was just like
you should fight like you should train
so i did it
three months later i fought damn yeah i
fought this girl who had like
and my debut was for legacy which is a
huge promotion
mick mayner now with the if ufc owned it
and
uh i fought a girl with five fights i
was just like some chick that used to
fight in school
and like learned like a couple punches
it was horrendous you can find on
youtube
it's horrendous it's horrendous like i
was swinging like
octopus arms but i was just tougher than
her and i retired her she never fought
after that
really yeah isn't that crazy too like i
there are certain fighters that i watch
that are just so
like for example like i always use this
guy as an example like mike perry is a
scrapper
right like when you see this guy on pads
or you see him training
you're like he might get [ __ ] up but
you put that fool in a cage people don't
know how to deal with his ferocity
because
how insane like mickey gall yeah he was
a growl he is a ground specialist
his [ __ ] yeah and he was getting out
grappled like a [ __ ] yeah but
the problem with those fighters is they
become
gatekeepers you know like uh the homie
donna cerrone actually i think cerrone
has potential to be champion but
people like that do become gatekeepers
because
when you when i mean that's what you
have and people can expect it and they
can work around it at high levels but
you'll see like these tough cats like go
through amateurs just
murdering people you know because
they're tough like i did yeah but if you
don't like get better at higher level
you're never gonna
you know because you have these
technicians that'll come and pick you
apart exactly that's why right now i'm
trying to
uh have that make that change in in my
career i think i'm very technical but
when i get into the fight i get really
emotional and
i just like love i just love fighting
and then so my coaches get mad because
in the gym i'm so much better and
they're like yo why are you still
hanging out like just take her down and
submit her already
you know but uh yeah it's hard to like
shift is it is it that much more
difficult
to perform out on that stage and on that
canvas than it is in the gym when you're
fighting people
like on a training basis like what's
what's the difference it depends on who
you are
there's like man you have these like gym
champs who
every sparring round you gotta [ __ ]
win and you know like
loves that and then they go and then
they go and they never make it anywhere
in their career
but then me it's just like it's fun in
the gym
um because i just don't really care if i
win or lose
you know so i'm just learning in the gym
but uh
is it easier to spar in the gym yeah for
sure because
but it's not as fun i don't think so
many rules
i mean i've been watching i've been
watching because i was just mentioning
this to you before like how
with with ufc fight nights you see fight
nights for me i would watch them maybe
half the time right i've been watching
every single one
the fights have been insane and then a
buddy of mine who was telling me um kind
of what you were talking about how
there's a difference between kind of
training and fighting in the gym versus
this
well now they don't have that crowd to
get in their brain yeah and so now they
get to fight at their full potential so
we've been watching these fight nights
where these fighters are coming out
and they look like they're you know top
20 fighters yeah and you don't even know
who they are
but it depends on fighters like i said
like you don't see it but it's subtle
the fighters that you see performing
really well right now those are the ones
that do well in the gym
because those are the ones that want to
be comfortable and have fun and then
there's ones that aren't performing as
well
because they love the energy the crowd
the pressure you know they love that
chip on their shoulder
i i don't know how i would perform i
would love to
see like i think my next event will i'm
sure the next events that i do will be
closed door and it's interesting to see
how i'll perform but do you prefer the
crowd there
i love the crowd you're [ __ ] nuts
like a crazy person
i love the crowd i love the screaming i
love the energy i love the heat i love
the lights i love it all that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah so how did you switch from going
from like muay thai
all the way to mma because i mean
obviously those practices are so
money oh really i did it because money
because
in muay thai i can't even imagine if you
grew up as a muay thai fighter in
thailand but even in america i was
fighting
every three weeks and it was just like
driving 11 hours cutting weight um
like hot boxing in a car trying to cut
weight on the way to a motel 6
where it's like crackheads staying next
door to you yeah to fight for free
you know and like that was just like the
career and the
the lifestyle of muay thai fighter and
then you get into a brac you go to
tournaments because there's not really
big fights so there's tournaments and
then you also
have like people that lie about their
age because there's no like
commission you know or their height or
their weight it's just nuts
i mean it's kind of fun but and then i
saw mma and i saw misha tate
and ronda rousey i was like yo they're
like doing interviews
they're like their hair is braided like
they have makeup on like
it was just it just felt like legit you
know that's why i say man like
corny as it can be because as it can
sound
representation is everything like i had
no idea you can do that until i saw them
and i was like nope get me to mma but i
wrestled in high school people don't
know that
oh really yeah i wrestled in high school
how many years
uh two and a half well about three years
off and on
that's dope yeah and i wrestled in
california so that's like the hardest
state to wrestle in
high school oh really poet you wrestle
boys too
yeah i sucked i i got murdered all
through high school because i always
wrestled boys
and then when i started training in
texas like there's girls that would swag
in there like yeah i'm state champ and i
would just murder them
this is a level of competition it's just
different like if you know somebody who
wrestled in california
sucky or not if they want or not they're
good like i had no idea that it was
co-ed in california
yes well i don't know if it is anymore
i'm 30. so it's like 15 years ago
because i didn't well i don't i didn't
know any female wrestlers in my high
school so
i think you know we i mean they could
correct me if i wrong but i only
remember boys wrestling so i don't yeah
and high school is definitely co-ed yeah
oh that's [ __ ] nuts so if you were a
girl wrestling you were wrestling some
boys
yeah and i was small and the boy the
small boys were the best
yeah the most athletic the like i
remember this one kid that murdered me
every season
he was like a cross country like champ
he's a soccer champ
and jesus oh yeah i wanted to like jump
him afterwards but
i'm just kidding what was it like
switching over to mma from kickboxing
um i didn't like the gym culture of mma
it's like a bunch of wannabes and a
bunch of like
show-offs and a bunch of like fake conor
mcgregor's and like
at least with muay thai you with muay
thai i think
the teachers are consistent and the
culture is consistent so there's if
you're
if you're like a wannabe or if you're
like fake about it
like the old schools will call you out
you know you ever if you ever train with
a thai
they're not impressed with anything they
don't care how much money you have
you're not allowed to get on the mat
unless you've been in a tie fight
like they just don't care but in in
america in mma culture if you have a
little bit of following or if you
whatever you could suck
and they'll still take you just because
of marketing or whatever i had
one because i i trained with my with my
buddy nick and we started off as fitness
and then later on he opened up and want
to try sparring and you know kind of
getting into it yeah but i trained at
this
in sacramento there was just one like
traditional like muay lao place
this [ __ ] because i've never
trained at a traditional like thai
loud gym he beat the [ __ ] out of me this
man
[ __ ] me up and i didn't expect it you
know so i was
you know cause these pad people they
don't hold pads yeah they're gonna hit
you
i didn't know so you know because he
asked me if i was like i trained a
little bit yeah you know just sand bag a
little just to see what he'll feel out
yeah but you know with that too i don't
think he appreciated
the fact that i kind of lied and he
[ __ ] me
up hell yeah you know it's like asian
culture it's like you
meet somebody's aunt they're not gonna
hug you they're gonna smack the [ __ ] out
of you
make fun of you and if you can get
through that then your family yeah
that's really how the culture is they're
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you they're
gonna make fun of you know honey oh walk
no good
kick no good you look like [ __ ] fat
american like
once you get through that and then
they're like okay he
yeah after we were done with the session
i fell asleep in my car for three hours
yeah
i couldn't move i've never trained that
hard before in my phone
he died and came back to life i i legit
died
he was like for the warm-up we did like
it was like 20 minutes of
ropes yeah and then we did like 200
sit-ups and it was like that's the
warm-up i'm like
i'm done like i don't have anything
that's why legit
muay thai schools don't last here in
america because they they love the dojo
feel
you know um but unless you came from
wrestling america
one sport in america uh one aspect of
mma in america that's tough is this
wrestling is just like the hardest thing
if you came from a wrestling school you
see all these like champs that are
kobe and tyron and all them are like
ex-wrestlers because they work hard you
know they're used to it
i feel like wrestlers are just it's
people are starting to realize how
important of a base that is
and it's just hard to deal with the
grappler yeah and especially if they're
if they don't want to stand with you
they don't have to stand they're just
going to wait for you to throw that
haymaker and then go for the double egg
yeah and then let's see how well you do
like you watch somebody like
hamza hamza the guy that just came out
he's like starting to blow up because he
thought
he's [ __ ] nuts yeah i i had no idea
because i hadn't seen anybody really
been able to do the
uh the dagestani handcuffs that well
right so there's only a few
there's habib and everybody else tries
to do it but somehow they always get out
scary because i'm telling you there's
probably like they probably have like a
den of like 20 of them waiting to
unleash like
on america you know like they're
probably like oh we got
khabib we got this guy and let's just
release all of them like oh [ __ ] they're
coming
just watching they're gonna murder he
got punched twice out of two fights
that's it two strikes
and i think he unloaded a total of like
250 or 300 strikes total out of those
two that's sick
and i i can't even imagine what that
feels like for that fighter cause it's
not like he's fighting people who are
like tuna cans yeah like they're newer
but they're still dope that's the thing
with casual fans they only see the
defeat physically right so like
oh yeah he beat the [ __ ] out of him
because he was punching him he's
bleeding
whatever right but the other loss that's
humiliating is a mental loss of not
being able to figure it out like
yo he's like slipping everything every
time you throw a punch he's taking you
down
you can't get up like you're drowning
with that handcuff and khabib and all
that it's like
yeah you you may not like it too much
because you only you only
recognize physical defeat you got to see
the mental defeat of like oh my god mom
please come get me
that was one of the reasons why i
started liking 1fc fights
was because the the crowd doesn't boo
and when they see them go to the ground
they're just as excited yeah to watch
what they can do on the ground as they
as they saw on the stand up yeah so they
were watching it from a real
fan perspective like they can see how
they're advancing in the fight yeah and
so in the ufc
i went to one ufc fight live and i'll
never go back again
yeah because it was the most obnoxious
thing i thought obnoxious
but you know they pay they do
they pay yo they pay but the thing about
one people understand is that like
the show is crazy it's crazy it's like a
concert
you get these like wristbands that go
with the music and then you have like
i mean it's like a whole ev it's like
you get your money's worth it's like a
whole event
at the ufc if i love going to ufc but
that's because i'm spoiled and i get
front row seats yeah
if i was sitting up high i wouldn't want
to go to the ufc because you can't see
anything you can't hear anything there's
no like crowd interactions throughout
the thing yeah yeah
yeah but one one is sick what were you
doing before you were assigned to want
to see
i was fighting for king of the cage oh
[ __ ]
yeah yeah she's [ __ ] tough too it's
all right oh
damn king of cage is all right um but
one thing i do like about king the cage
is like
they really highlighted adam weights and
there was nowhere in america that did
that yeah they they really started that
and then come back they started
highlighting adam weights after
but um no i had a harsh ending to king
of the cage because
i just couldn't cut to 105 anymore i
think people think
it's deceiving because i'm so short yeah
people are like it should be easy for
you to want to go to 105 i'm like no yo
it's not easy i mean just weight cutting
in general
i mean what's that whole experience i
mean i i don't understand how people can
cut weight like it
i don't know if your body just gets used
to it or dead like just watching jorge
lose 20 pounds in six days
it's just a mind [ __ ] like i don't even
really remember what
wait i don't even think i have a real
perception
of what weight cutting is like because
the entire time
i'm fooling myself that i'm doing
something else like
the entire time i'm like oh it's fine
you know i'm not even hungry
whatever like i'm just constantly
mindful do that teach me how to do that
i'm always hungry
yeah i'm i'm yeah it's like my
perception of reality i can i can i can
manipulate
my head like my mind that's you know
that's really the the game because i
mean if you don't you're just sitting in
hunger and you're just sitting in like
dehydration you're sitting in like
your lower back your knees start
buckling lower back start aching
ah these are the physical things you
feel um you get lightheaded
so like drilling near the fight um
don't be the [ __ ] that if somebody
has fight or close to their fight
drill hard because every time you get
pushed your brain's like rattling
oh oh really yeah because you're
dehydrated you're cutting weight
so every time like somebody drills hard
i'm like oh my god
yeah yeah so you i mean it's rough have
you seen cyborg crying
that was a really harsh video to watch
just watching her go through that that
mental trauma of just
first of all she's a [ __ ] animal and
to watch her be that
vulnerable and just bawling because she
just wanted it to stop
made me feel [ __ ] terrible and people
don't really empathize with her because
they're like well it's your fault for
being that big i'm like well
there's no higher weight class for her
yeah she has no choice that's probably
what the tears are from i don't think
the tears are from the pain the tears
are from just
this is my only choice like there's
nowhere to go from here you know
like that's why i'm happy at one because
i can take harder hits now i've been
dropped
in king of the cage and i've i've fought
people where i'm like what
like that's not my skill level you know
yeah it's just from
the weight cut that kind of that rocks
you yeah my last fight at king the cage
i got murdered
by a girl that i beat quite easily
before
not taking anything away from her but
i'm actually kind of over
like explaining myself with that it is a
way cut but the fight was awake
yeah you don't have like i got dropped
three times
and then she choked me out and i don't
remember any of it and i just remember
after that loss
my coaches went back michelle was like
giving me a speech and stuff and i'm
like yo it's fine i'm just glad it's
over
and then my coach was like what did you
say i was like i'm just glad it's over
he was like you need a [ __ ] break
yeah because you're not even sad you
lost yeah i was just tired
yeah i was like i'm so glad it's over i
don't know
because i don't wait cut you know i
don't i don't know what the [ __ ] that
really feels like so i don't know
how taxing it is and how draining it is
but i do know that
when people miss weight yeah like by
five pounds i don't want to see that
fight
yeah because statistically they always
win and there's there has to be a reason
for it but if you're missing weight by
five
[ __ ] pounds it's like did you even
try you know like what the [ __ ]
yeah and it's rough when you watch in
the ufc because it's such high level
high stakes and they cut so much in the
ufc
at one i mean honestly i don't really
care if you're missing weight or
whatever because none of us are cutting
water
you know it's like oh is is is there
weight is is it how do they do the
weight
the you throughout the week with your
pain
yeah your pee is tested throughout the
week and you know what's funny the first
time i did it
i thought i was good because i was
hydrated i didn't cut water our even our
perception as
regular humans not even fighters of what
dehydrate is is not
because i failed my first test my very
first fight at one and i wasn't even
cutting water
i was like drinking regular so now i
have to chug
now i'm like more aware of how hydrated
a human actually has to be to be
hydrated
like i was not hydrated i had no idea i
didn't know that's what one fc did
yeah that's pretty uh nice no yeah we
our p gets tested
like throughout the week so in return
though like people that
like if you look at angela lee stamp
fair text people ask like yo they're
much bigger in business yeah
but they still go through the same exact
test they just have to do it harder
because
people like them have to starve like
they don't really get to eat
but your brain is still healthy you can
go without food
yeah your body's still healthy with
water even if you eat if you dehydrate
water
that is bad you can't do that to your
body especially if you're gonna do
combat sports
so yeah they still have to cut in a
sense that they fight week they kind of
don't eat
but they're still drinking gallons of
water um
you can survive people do fast all the
time yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh i didn't know well i guess that's a
lot safer for the fighter then so much
safer i mean
yeah so much safer i don't know how sage
would be
if i mean he'd fought in the u.s i saw
the
it was when cejudo uh tko'd [ __ ] tj
dillashaw
and you saw tj he looked like a skeleton
and look at aldo oh man and like when
you look at that and you say
oh they're ready to go for fighting i'm
like damn i don't know about that
you know even all those last fight when
he was fighting peter young for the belt
right
he gassed out so [ __ ] bad and he
looked great in those first two rounds
that's the thing people just think like
we're superhuman
we're not super human physically we have
the same exact body
we are super human mentally as athletes
like so when you see aldo like that and
you're like oh he's fine he's an athlete
he can do it no
he looks like that for a reason yeah
that's not healthy
although his mind he's mind [ __ ]
himself and he's ready mentally
like what you see is really what you get
physically he looks bad
and his body probably is doing bad you
know and there's certain fighters too
that now they're they're going up in
weight class and they're seeing a lot
more success
yeah because their chin is way [ __ ]
better they're taking these hits
a lot better and their stamina is so
much better too yeah i just feel bad for
the people who are in between there's a
lot of in-betweeners who are like
like kevin lee not quite big enough yeah
and then they go up and then they fail
and they come back down
and stuff like that so he's one of those
people
tough yeah yeah he's like he's literally
he needs that weight class in between
yeah it's hard for him to find that good
success in both those areas and it's
kind of hard watching because such a
dope fighter
it's so tough because at least now at
one if i lose or get knocked out or
something i'm like yo
i mean i just wasn't good enough i need
to work harder but then like
when i'm cutting so much i'm like yo was
it a cut like was i was dizzy all fight
week
like you know like i was you know shaky
and all this stuff
at least now it's like win or lose it's
on me and all my i mean
how easy it is i mean how do you fight
like that like i don't
i don't remember that fire that's what
i'm saying no idea it's kind of nuts how
i
is it because a lot of the times because
i mean you've trained and you've drilled
so much
when you're so mentally depleted and
physically depleted a lot of this just
has to be instincts at a certain point
right it's a mind [ __ ] too
yeah it's all a mind we're just
sometimes like if you see fighters cut
so much weight and they just kill it
i mean they're probably surprised they
killed it they're just
like their body's just like a zombie and
their brains powering them through all
of that
yeah honestly like i said i don't
remember way cuts why doesn't the ufc do
the
hydration test i think that's like a
very smart thing to do for fighters oh
because they're so big
and they're i don't know
why why doesn't a lot of big companies
change an entire system it's scary
and it's not that eminent yet like they
don't think it's that important you know
and they're not that concerned with
changing culture
i don't know i don't know what they
think it's fine probably
and it's fine i mean whatever you're the
athlete at the end of the day exactly
doesn't have to do that but they want
you you don't have to you're signing up
to do it you know
yeah i think it'd be cool if they did
the hydration thing um
but it's gonna shift their entire
rankings it's gonna shift everybody's
performance it's going to shift their
entire system
um it's a lot to change would you ever
entertain the
the thought of like going to the to the
ufc
yeah yeah i mean growing up in america
i've
always wanted to be in the ufc that was
like the it but
um i wasn't just gonna wait around
forever you know
for them to do adam wait um so i went to
one and i'm happy at one though like one
honestly i did i don't know i didn't
know what to think going in but man i'm
like legitly
i don't hear a single fighter ever
complain about 1fc yeah
but there's not a single fighter that
ever says anything bad about that
promotion yeah and people think like
people think like we're made to say good
things like no if you know me
i keep it real i don't give a [ __ ]
nobody can like censor
how i feel about something and i love
one yeah it's sick
um yeah it's sick like it's good like
they
obviously um people like angela lee who
are
undefeated um get celebrated and become
champ but also they value fighters like
me
who i lose sometimes i win sometimes but
i'm like one of the most entertaining
fighters out there
people like to see heart in fighting i
think yeah it's that
weird balance of you kind of get to pick
and choose what you like right so if you
like technicians you like people
to win yeah then some there's there's a
reason why even like kamara usman he has
fans but there's also
an understanding of why people don't
like kamar usman a lot you know they
don't like his fighting style yeah
that's completely fine too
yeah i mean he's he is uh
he's a specialist he does what he does
really really well which is step on feet
and then not playing around but he like
kamaru uzman does what he does well i
can't knock him for it he's sick
like nobody i think if you appreciate
grappling and you appreciate what he
does in the ring
it's very easy to love him he's sick but
for people who like who only want to see
jeremy stevens
yeah it's going to be hard for you to
watch kamaru's man i mean but kamaru
doesn't really need you to like him he's
the champ
exactly people like people that fight
smart but don't have the most fans
because they don't think it's
entertaining or whatever it didn't
doesn't really matter because they have
the belt
and then people like me who kind of risk
the win sometimes
like you don't have to you don't
understand does fighters like me risk
the winds like there's a couple of
fights where
like i could have just i should have
taken them down and just this is what i
should do from now on but
i could have taken them down and just
like laid on them and and got the win
but i just want to [ __ ] fight because
i love i love
like the gratification from you know of
like just letting it all out
and i think fighting is like every human
on this earth wants to know what they're
made of at the end of the day
cool getting lambos are dope getting
[ __ ] are dope getting money's dope
but at the end of the day what do you
really want you want to know what you're
made of like what you can really do
right and so fighting is like a
representation of that
so that's why you pick you pick fighters
to be fans of
that you think is the best of you you
know like there's a lot of people like
math [ __ ] love cowboy because he's a
badass and he's you know
that's why i always tell people
sometimes when they it's
there's like this weird concept of when
you're when you're a fight fan right and
you kind of touched on it there where i
just had this conversation where people
were asking
it's you know how come these fight fans
you know they never fight but they
always have an opinion about these
fights all the time like they don't know
what it's like
it's because they want to be those
people yeah i don't mind it yeah like i
don't want it
you shouldn't mind it because the of
course they go well
because one of the top comments that
you'll always see on these ufc fan pages
like
well you're you're not you're not in
there you're not a fighter of course no
[ __ ] i'm a fan that's what i'm
commenting
exactly exactly they're they're fans
they they want to be in those positions
so yeah
they're going to talk out of line and
out of turn because yeah they literally
wish
that they had those abilities yeah so
they're talking about it from a fan
perspective
so sometimes on this podcast too like
one of my friends like oh you was like
you don't like
i forgot what fire that i was mentioning
that i'm not a big fan of they're like
well
it was like would you say that to their
face and i was like no i probably
wouldn't because they're a nice person
and they'll [ __ ] me up yeah you don't go
up to somebody and say you [ __ ] suck
exactly as uh any sports fan would i
have an opinion about the sport
not about them as a human being you know
yeah yo i get
empathizing and and all that with
celebrities or athletes and stuff
um i mean don't be terribly mean like
you said don't go up to them and just
like make them question their whole life
but like that's what we're here for
we're here for entertainment yeah
i'm gonna pick and choose which fighters
i like like doesn't mean
like it doesn't mean that they're not
gonna [ __ ] me up or [ __ ] up any layman
yeah but i'm talking like do people get
offended about that in basketball
i like i love i love jordan but i'm not
a big fan of [ __ ] lawrence
thunderbird
or if i make a [ __ ] show and i'm like
you don't watch my show no i don't like
it yeah
it is what it is good yeah yeah i didn't
believe you when you cried
you're not that good yes people are too
much man honestly
i i i don't mind it there's people that
like throw my record in my face i'm like
yo i know it's on the internet it's fine
and then there's people who are like yo
but have you seen these fights though
yeah you know i always tell people like
when they ask about me you fight i'm
like yeah look me up on youtube
not google because my stats are like my
stats are right
yeah but like my videos are sick you
know my highlights are sick so it's
it's whatever dude that that record
thing i think when you start to become a
fan of fighting or
what i do suggest for people to if you
are a really big mixed martial arts
boxing or whatever like combat
uh combat sport fan yeah you should
train and the reason why i say that is
because it makes the fights that much
more fun
yeah you could see things that you never
saw before from a
from a spectator's perspective yeah it's
just more fun do you want to watch
football with
his wife or with him him because he
knows the game like his wife's not gonna
know
like okay some wives i'm not doing the
whole gender some wives know football
okay but
what i'm saying is it's just more fun to
know what the hell is going on yeah when
i
when i started training and then i think
one of what i told my buddy nick was
when we first started training i told
him like the reason why i want to train
is because i'll be real like when i was
watching ufc and i watched it for a long
time when i was younger
yeah whenever i went to the ground i
didn't know what was going on yeah just
except for the basic stuff so i was like
this can be so much more fun if i know
what's happening yeah
and then when we started training and we
started going through the stuff like i
started seeing everything
i'm like holy [ __ ] this this fight is
[ __ ] nuts
and it's more exciting i'm screaming
like you like unlike
unwrapped like this whole this is a
whole new world dude
i'm like yo i'm on a [ __ ] magic
carpet this is nuts so
when that's when um just appreciating
grappling started
uh happening from yeah and i know i
started watching like polaris and all
sorts of stuff
and now i'm i'm starting to see the
setups i'm starting to see what these
fighters are trying to do and when they
get it it's [ __ ] satisfying but
they're still like boring grapplers you
know and then there's still [ __ ]
people like khabib who you just
see somebody drowning underneath them
like holy crap when i watch him fight
somebody i feel bad for the fighter
yeah because i they look desperate they
go in their mind they go
i've been working this whole camp yeah
to fight a grappler
yeah and they go do not get here and
[ __ ] i'm here
it still wasn't enough when people were
like get up i'm like
all right i know all right cool i'll
throw your ass in the ocean and tell you
get up get out of the ocean full that
was the
the hard thing to deal with because when
we were first kickboxing and then
a nick would just [ __ ] around and then
he would go for a double leg right yeah
i just couldn't see it
yeah i'm like i i there was no way i
would have defended that you feel
violated right i do
i feel like a little [ __ ] i'm like how
the [ __ ] i thought we were boxing yeah
but just just going from that yeah and
then uh
another buddy of mine after he did that
i was just like hold on a second let me
let me figure this stuff out i gotta
learn
i gotta at least know how to stuff a
takedown yeah you were like
xb l2 i know this [ __ ]
and then a buddy of mine when we were
kickboxing he got a little frustrated
and he just wanted to [ __ ] around he
went for a double leg but we went over
how to stuff it and i stuffed it and it
felt very empowering
it's like you're not going to get this
for free you've got to work for this
[ __ ] yeah and it was
that's how women feel when we turn you
off when are we turning you all down
you don't get this [ __ ] for free [ __ ]
with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
exactly and uh that's why i i feel like
a lot of people should just train in
general it's it's number one it's
humbling and what i like about finding
the most and i mentioned this before on
this podcast is that
specifically when it comes to muay thai
grappling in jiu jitsu
you can't lie yeah this isn't taekwondo
yeah
taekwondo because i did taekwondo my
whole life yeah people just give you
belts if you give them money yeah muay
thai there's no [ __ ] belt
no you know it's you come in you get
better that's what's different about the
sport you really find out what you're
made of i've seen like
nfl guys come in and i'll piece them up
you know i've seen like
you come in it's either going to be
instant gratification or
instant punishment you know and if
you're truly on a journey to find out
what you're really made of
then you'll get better because you're
gonna be told you're not as good as you
thought you were you're not as tough as
you
the sport is gonna tell you you ain't
[ __ ] yeah but if you're just strong
enough to realize all right but i wanna
be [ __ ]
then you gotta get through it you know
like it's not it's not
it's not easy so so i think that's um
i think that's that's what i tell people
there's a video of my buddy bart
uh he they were just kind of yeah i'm
bart i hope he's about to say something
good because he's
through his whole name out there well
bart the video's on the youtube so
you'll see
but he you know carlos barza he went all
the way to oyama
and just to have a light little light
spar session toss him on his head and
she
[ __ ] him up she's a college collegiate
wrestler well she's not collegiate but
she's college wrestling you know and
it's kind of crazy because you think in
your mind and i asked bart i was like
did you kind of play it safe he goes
well for the first few seconds in my
mind i think i'm a bigger guy oh yeah
and then she grabs me and he goes i
really have to try
yeah yeah every sparring session with a
new guy with me starts like
this they kind of always do this like
like i'm not really going to hit you
thing then i boop and i hit them
and then they start tightening up and
they're like all right okay
no free hits now this is going to hurt
yeah
well that's the thing like when you're a
professional fighter you're a [ __ ]
professional fighter it is what it
[ __ ] is
yeah it's fine it's fun because what
people need to understand when they come
to the gym
is that we've all been [ __ ] up it is
okay
if i [ __ ] you up if you [ __ ] me up it's
it's just fine like
it's not no one's gonna remember nobody
cares i think the humbling thing was
like
um when i was training was to it really
helped me put in perspective
there's this there's it's weird right
how
sometimes there's a gap between a
regular person in an amateur fight and
obviously the amateurs are the pro
right but there's some people who'd say
that they fight a lot but they just had
big mouths
and i think that was the most
disappointing thing for me because prior
to that if somebody just told me that
they were an amateur
kickboxer right i'm thinking oh this guy
will [ __ ] me up that's the mma community
for you man
i'm telling you and then you come in and
then you trade blows with them and
you're lighting this guy up and it's
like you talked so much [ __ ]
yeah and like there was one guy i
literally had a conversation with him i
was like
you should have [ __ ] me up all day
today yeah i was like you came in
talking all this other [ __ ]
yeah trying to teach me how to do all
this other stuff like critiquing my [ __ ]
yeah and we just sparred and i just lit
you up and i'm not good so what the [ __ ]
are you
you know not [ __ ] and so it made me feel
lied to
almost like i felt a little dirty like
you lied to me that happens
every single day and i don't even know
why they do it because yeah it's
literally like
you can't lie we're gonna we're gonna
punch each other in the face there was
like this guy at
tiger muay thai is why i train and i
train in the muay thai area and
not all even if you're a ufc fighter
only if you come from muay thai or if
you know muay thai and you're pro
you get to be in the muay thai practice
pro practice
like there's a lot of ufc fighters that
aren't allowed to come it just depends
on
it's muay thai you know so there's some
guy that came over and he was like
i want to spar and the thai coach was
like ignoring him
he said i want to spar he was like okay
let me see
he was like what let me see and then he
started shadow ball he's like no you
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] everything [ __ ] no no no no no
no and then he waved him away
and then they got really upset and then
they quit the gym wow
well it's just like you don't see in
america like we're
when we don't that's not receptive like
you people don't receive that well so
they don't
people kind of humor people more here
you know i i watched the
uh tiger muay thai doc the the tryouts
oh [ __ ]
i um i almost cried watching people
and i had no idea did you have to do the
tryout too no
oh my god that i did not say that in a
stuck up way i said that in a thank
goodness way because i wouldn't have
done it like
we sit there and watch like i'm already
like uh they just did two tryouts i
watched two of them and i was already
part of the
i'm a sponsored fighter there so like
and in asia
one obviously is like ufc so we're like
sponsored you know
so i'm sitting there like just watching
like oh
so like but when they win those tryouts
like mike davis he's in the ufc now
davis is [ __ ] dope he his i was there
at his tryouts he killed it
and when they win it we're just like
giving him rounds like whatever he needs
you need me to drill like because we
respect you now
like we saw you go through that like i
just think the ties just
need something you have to just earn it
like they just you just need to give
them something
that's why they have these kind of
tryouts you know that most other gyms
don't have because they're like we don't
know you you can't just walk you go we
got to show you something
you got to show them tryouts where the
the pad holders are
[ __ ] these guys up hi pat holding i
in i would have cried like the moment
people do
i would have broke down because it's not
like they do
they're not they're not even doing it
for show they're cracking oh they don't
care about the show
yeah yeah and they're just like
afterwards after this guy is just had
like his the spirit beaten out of him
he goes he's pretty good like hey [ __ ]
you guys
i'm dead because of you yeah they're
like hey you want to go eat
it's like after you just beat the living
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me yeah and
only thais know how to do that not that
they know how but they just don't have
that like
boundary because i remember one time the
thai
oh they have like a muay thai day then
they have a boxing day and conditioning
day
the boxing coaches they're just from a
technical boxing thing you know they
were like trying to make it tough
but it looked like a normal practice you
just can't mimic what the ties will do
you because our boxing coaches were just
not like ready to like
sock them in the face like the boxing
part is just not as fun and just to
watch as the muay thai part
that's what i was watching also i was
kind of surprised with the guy at that
gym in sacramento i didn't realize
how traditional he is so when i walked
in for the first time and he had those
classic old puzzle mats and whatever
who uh i can't remember his name
anymore but i i only heard from alva
mill no no no no no not master tong
um he's just like a traditional muay lau
guy like
he trained in laos and everything okay
this guy like i had no idea but right
when i walked in i saw the shrine i saw
the incense and i had to bow and do the
whole thing i was like yeah this is
gonna be a bad day also
another tip if he's drinking what looks
like coke
get out of this if you're not ready if
you're not ready
if you're not about that life it is not
coke in there when thais are drunk
they are so good at pad holding but
they're so mean
yeah my crew like when he quit drinking
i could tell because he was leaning out
i'm like yo happy for you but i don't
want you to hold pads for me anymore
it was like what i'm like you're better
drunk you know like yo who the hell is
this i would have just gone and gotten
a western battle there you know what's
the what's what's like the reasoning for
them to be like so tough is it because
it's necessary
like what's why has it been like that
for so long yo
it's the thing is it's not as it's not
it is a sport let me see this the right
way
it is a survival type of sport out there
you know
it's to in
in asian culture usually i'm not
speaking for everybody
but there are a lot of misfortunes
there's a lot of underprivileged things
but you kind of just suck it up
in order to get through life you know
and the same thing with sport like you
accept things and you just move on you
just keep going you don't really
fight the system you don't really fight
you know and and you just got to really
earn it
and so the old schools are just like
that you really just gotta earn it
and there's like um there's a pride in
it though you know
there's a lot of fighters you'll meet in
america where like yeah you know i
fought pro
but there's so many of them so [ __ ]
saturated and they didn't go through
anything so it doesn't really mean
anything unless you were in the ufc or
bellator but in thailand you could be
anybody if you've gone through a thai
camp and fought
in thailand everybody will respect you
just because we know what you went
through
when you when you be or before you
became a pro fighter were you
were you somebody that just liked the
fight in general i had to i grew up in
oakland what part of oakland uh east
oakland oh yeah you grew up in the fight
you were [ __ ] the cut yeah you know
so it's like i grew up in
yeah i grew up in them so just to get
people out there if you're not from the
bay area because i'm from sacramento
like i
we used to go kick it around oakland
like easter did you why
uh just a lot of homies were out there
so okay but that place was
i was terrified yeah i mean and mind you
like i'm not a thug i just grew up
around people who
happen to do gang [ __ ] and they would
let me still hang out with them
so i would hang out with them right but
they know i'm not about their life so
they're very protective of me
but i remember so when i was driving
back home one day
and this is when i knew i was like oh
east oakland is not a nice place there
was just a gang that was in front of a
[ __ ] freeway
and they were taking toll for people to
even go through they're like nah you got
it that's
actually common in the project so every
time you drive into the projects there's
kids waiting in front
so the 10 from like if you're nine to
like 15 in
in the projects that's your job to see
who's coming in there and if there's
cops or anything bad coming in you let
everybody else know
that's the hotel yeah and so when i was
when i was there and i remember i was
like damn like i grew up in
maybe not the most nicest area in
sacramento but i was like east oakland
is something different
yeah you know like certain parts like
that modesto stockton
not all poor neighborhoods are dangerous
but dangerous neighborhoods
are dangerous you know are the same age
so east oakland at that time was
bad crackers it was [ __ ] nuts yeah it
was black panthers and
and yeah yeah it was a lot but i'm proud
of oakland in the sense that it's very
progressive you know
like there's a lot of like changes come
out of oakland but yeah it was
it was rough and i'm a little asian girl
you know and i don't take any [ __ ]
because also it's not just from being
open that i'm tough i'm also a refugee
you know vietnamese refugee you put that
together there's like no feelings at
home like what's a feeling
there's no feelings at home and then
when you go to i actually think
it was being asian and immigrant that
made me tougher
because that i would like we came from
vietnam you know and i would go even in
the projects they'd be like
complaining i'm like yo you get food
stamps and air conditioning
i came from a [ __ ] village like you
know
this is this is there was there was this
rapper the sudanese rapper named bangs
the funniest guy i think he's to him
he's a serious rapper but to the rest of
the world i'll show you a video later
it's the funniest [ __ ]
he has a strong video here yes he had a
song called let me take you to the
movies the funny
wait what i'll show you you'll [ __ ]
dial up theater
yes so this guy he had this line that
was the most fire [ __ ] line ever
because of how real it was
he was like he said he goes a lot of
these rappers out there is talking about
they have it hard i don't even have
shoes
at all bats that's why i'm like people
are like scared of francis and ghana i'm
like don't be scared of his size
be scared that he's from the [ __ ]
village and he will
like stop at nothing to beat you dude
when i see france as a godu in a cage
i go i wonder what the other fighter is
thinking right now
well so i started re-watching a lot of
francis's fight
and i i didn't realize that before he
knocks somebody out
the other person actually connects a hit
before his hit
it just doesn't do [ __ ] to him yeah but
also it's the heart you know like let's
go back to the stage in cosmo fight
something's happening here um like sage
is fighting for what
glory fame and to make his parents proud
yeah cosmo's fighting for life
cosmo is fighting with a chip on the
shoulder that he's been a 10 time
world champion and nobody knows him and
here's this kid comes in with all this
fame and he's supposed to be fed to this
kid
that's what cosmo is fighting for you
know that's why people are like b you're
so small but you're inspiring because
you fight hard
yeah because i'm a refugee and immigrant
i grew up in the hood like i'm fighting
for so
much you know what i mean and so like
that that
that is a huge difference like mike
perry people don't know mike perry comes
from a rough
rough neighborhood and he has a lot of
trauma in his life you know
oh people can't tell from jesus
was chilling you know mickey gall had
like
daycare and like babysitters man so
that's so funny that you were talking
about this because
i feel like a lot of the people that i
connect with are also people who grew up
in a a similar social economic situation
that i did right
yeah there's something about the world
view how you view things how you
appreciate things and how you respect
things
yeah that's different when you didn't
grow up with a lot of things yeah and so
it's true like when you see somebody
like mickey gall and you see somebody
like mike perry
who you know he's dealing with a lot of
mental [ __ ] right now yeah but when
somebody grew up in the cuts and you try
to take
he's like you're trying to take a bone
away from a dog when that's all he has
he's not going to let you get that bone
that easy i like i dated a fighter from
my gym a long time ago like six years
ago
and he is a martial artist we used to
always say and i'm a fighter
you know now i've learned to infuse the
two but
like he was just like so much better
than me yeah
he just didn't have the heart i had you
know so he didn't make it anywhere in
his career but
like there's two different things i
think you know like in that fight mike
perry was a fighter
and mickey gall was a martial artist
yeah i'm not gonna pretend to know i'm
mickey carl's
background but i can just kind of tell
you kind of see it you know
mike perry it's it's maybe it's that
whole thing of like
it reminds me of um when mma started
exposing a lot of traditional martial
arts
right and traditional martial arts yeah
if you get a heel
if you can [ __ ] he'll hook somebody
in the head fantastic one of the most
powerful kicks that has ever existed in
martial arts
can you get it done though you know and
that's like that difference when people
started seeing like taekwondo it has a
lot of its uses in martial arts yeah
but that alone is a martial art it's not
battle tested exactly that's why i love
ring tested like yeah that's why now i'm
gonna start doing like
technique videos and things like that i
never thought about doing form like what
the [ __ ] there's plenty out there you
know but i'll look through youtube and
it's all like these people from dojos
i'm like yo that's not gonna help a real
fighter in the in the ring
there's a guy that i'll use for example
this guy his name is dku right he's a
korean guy he's the one that's treating
uh he got really famous because these
videos of him showing off um
not showing off that's the wrong word
but he was doing a demonstration
for special ops people like how to
disarm and fight he's a very very fast
guy
yeah right but you watch his sparring
footage that's where it's not battle
tested it's like
these people i think your stuff works
great on people who haven't had a single
ounce of fighting history
yeah but you have somebody who's a
fighter who scraps it's not going to be
that easy
i think that's the problem really too
with people out here is like
life and martial arts is it's okay to
find your lane
it's when you think you're supposed to
be in this other lane
that you ain't equipped for that's the
problem like it's okay to be
like flashy move guy you know
but don't try to teach fighters
raymond daniels is a great example of a
guy who's flashy but
battle tested as [ __ ] as [ __ ] you know
what i mean watching him
box was or kickbox he's a freaking
nature it's like
how many crews or like you know like
i used to be coached by cub swanson a
lot of things he did i'm like oh i'm not
doing that
yes i can't do it i'm not you i'm not
i'm yeah a cartwheel kick
sweet what i'm not doing i'm getting
knocked out so like
you know a lot of people will get misled
in that way that they see their
favorite fighter like don't just watch
jon jones and think you can do what he
does
yeah i think that's just for anybody who
who sees like a talent that somebody
else has
you have to find your lane right so i
think even when i
when i first started um kickboxing i
tried doing as traditional muay thai at
first as
as long as i could but you know i
started in taekwondo and i think i
started finding more success mixing the
both
instead of trying to just do something
and i think that's important for people
when you find coaches
and a coach will be able to find what
your greatest abilities are yeah and
then heighten that instead of telling
them you should work what i tell you to
do yeah you know i mean people always
say like damn b you've been at all the
gyms i'm like yeah i haven't found
like i mean i love tiger i think i found
my spot
tiger but um it's not a it's not
a testament to the coach's skill
it's the can you do you vibe with me
as a person and as me stylistically or
how i am you know
at tiger it's very independent a lot of
fighters wouldn't like tiger because
some fighters like to be babysat through
their whole schedule and whatever
tiger everybody's doing their own thing
like everybody when you show up when you
want to and if you don't show up the
coach is not going to chase you you're
just going to lose a fight
so that's why they really they kind of
find those specific people who
were kind of gonna they know that
they're here to win yeah and and it's
they'll drop you any day if you if you
want to come out there and be like
spoiled because they deal with asian
fighters out there and that's the
difference with one too and i wish that
more people would be inclined to watch
it because
there's like stories like sama pet who's
like a
thai legend he used to pick up trash for
a living just to like feed his family
you know oh [ __ ] and now he's fighting
on one there's people like that like
this girl i fought uh bozina she's a um
uh lumpini no what's it called listen
away champion
lift the weight is bare knuckle play
it's [ __ ] nuts so
these people are fighting for their
lives and they're fighting for the
families they're fighting for legacy so
you're really going to see some bomb ass
fights yeah it's not like
you're going to see some fighters where
it's like all right cool whatever onto
the next
i got a big paycheck watching eddie
alvarez go into one fc
and then getting his time we did the
camp together
timothy is my teammate we did camp
together and you should see timothy he's
like
no stopping him dude that [ __ ] was crazy
and i was like
welcome to 1fc huh i was like 1fc i mean
yeah eddie alvarez was a little older
but he is definitely top tier in the ufc
too
he was still dope yeah and he caught it
he got [ __ ] smashed
yeah i'm talking about he went he went
head-to-head with poirier so
you know watching that fight i was my
jaw dropped yeah of course
ufc has the best in the world but so
does one and
yeah especially i will tell you now if
you're a lighter fighter coming to ufc
you need to
you need to research you need to be
careful because like
these 35ers 25ers 45ers holy moly
you fought they they have uh ring
promotions too it's not just the case i
thought stamping a ring
that's that was my biggest mistake in my
what was that entire career holy crap
she was so comfortable with the clinch
so like if you if you
i watch the fight over and over again um
it's actually
i think one of the greatest uh female
fight not to
not because of me it's just i watched
over an event of one fc because
like if i watch the fight from my end
from beginning to end i'm like okay b
you did the double leg good you reaped
good like i did everything right
her clench was just superior and like
and she was so comfortable
they can kind of sit on the rope you
know they can kind of lean on the rope
and then they can they can clench you
out and move like
it's just i was just i thought i was
coming in there with mma experience
because it was mma
but she brought in ring experience and i
was like holy [ __ ]
yeah because against the cage i can lean
against them and reap them down a lot
like slide them you've seen that right
slide them down or like trip them or
whatever but in the ring i just couldn't
like she was just so
set in the rings that was the i think
that's like one of those things where um
where i'm watching these fights and you
see somebody with a great clinch game
yeah and it's like having a lobster just
grab hold of you and you're [ __ ]
dude and it's humiliating because like
it's more painful the knees like it hurt
yeah
i didn't show it because i'm crazy and
adrenaline that's the thing that i
always see like
when i watch fighters and they just take
a leg kick because if we're sparring and
somebody hits with the leg kick i go
time's out i'm like that [ __ ] locks up
i'm like you
[ __ ] dick like i can't move my leg
yeah and then i just see fighters just
take it
like a full-on full blast sat down leg
kick and they go and they're still
bouncing i'm like
no that happens so often in one when
fighters from other countries come over
and they don't know how to check a leg
kick
their legs just smashed because these
guys are just
it's bad there's like a small little
clip that i have in my phone of just
because nick and i were sparring a
little bit you know he always goes easy
on me but yeah uh i had shin guards
and i think he forgot he didn't he hit
me with one leg kick and i was like
the inside of my leg was [ __ ] bruised
all the way up
i was like [ __ ] this guy that [ __ ] hurts
so bad and i was like man i'm not about
this life huh if you're ever in asia do
not if you don't have your shin guards
or you forgot go home
don't even go cause yeah you're gonna
die
like if you don't have your shin guards
they will kick you as hard as that you
can because they find it like
disrespectful like you know
oh my god they will [ __ ] you up bro
how do you when when you train versus
like an asian over here is asia always
tougher
yeah damn here well here the wrestling's
tough
like wrestling practices in america are
[ __ ] sick
yeah um wrestling's over over there the
the coach george
hickman he's really good but the general
public just isn't that good yet
so it's a i'm like wrestling i'm like
yes and everybody's like oh my god it's
wrestling
but when it's like muay thai day it's
like oh [ __ ]
it's gonna be rough it's gonna be rough
you know um
definitely i have seen fighters over
there that are fighting for trump change
that are trying to make it in the world
and it kind of breaks my heart because i
don't have the opportunities that a lot
of people have here in america
they are just sick there's like 16 year
olds that'll
kill a lot of pro fighters here that
i've like as far as striking yeah yeah
you know
yeah so it's just it's eye-opening we're
watching a lot of these like elite
kickboxers
they come in and if they have
good defense right if you can't take
that double leg on them or you can't
take the single leg you can't drag them
like sonia is a great example he's not
going to let you touch him and people
are like yeah they were talking mad [ __ ]
now i've been a huge honestania fan so
when he came in you'll see i got really
hyped
yeah but you know him during kickboxing
yeah
i mean he got knocked out once i forgot
who the guy was that guy that's talking
[ __ ] now
yeah yeah i mean he got knocked out once
but prior to that i mean
he was an amazing kickboxer specifically
just because of
the his tool bag was so huge yeah just
watching him doing his question
question mark kick i just loved watching
him fight yeah but when he came to the
ufc even i was concerned to see
how he was going to deal with these
takedowns and i'm like people cannot
take this point down
yeah he's athletic man and some people
just get it yeah it just i feel like
he's just his fight iq so high
yeah some people just get it like and
then some people have like like stamp i
have pretty good wrestling
and i couldn't take her down because of
her clinch jesus yeah and
that's why i'm really interested in
seeing her and angela lee because
angela uses the clinch to take get her
takedowns and i'm like um
oh oh oh whoa yeah whoa whoa
we might have a problem there but yeah
when you um
go to a fight right and i always
wondered about this too specifically
with fighters like
um is there some kind of like mental
like downfall that you have from from
taking a loss or is that something that
you just take well because
you've had like a harder upbringing
because sometimes when i watch fighters
and i see how they take these losses
and i'm always worried about their next
fight yeah to see how it's going to [ __ ]
them up mentally because
specifically undefeated fighters they
have the worst i was just going to say
that my first loss was probably the
worst
my first loss as a pro was like the
worst thing ever because also i was like
real built up
like i was like i had fans in my amateur
career like if i was pro
and so like then i went pro and i was
3-0 and then everybody was like oh my
gosh
it's the next big thing and then i lost
and i was like holy [ __ ] i suck
like literally dramatic i was like i
suck that's it
you know it's like managing your
expectations when you you know you think
you're this much and then you lose it
breaks more
but when you know you're not invincible
then you can deal with it better then
you can just compartmentalize it like
all right it was a loss cool we'll move
on
you know but if you've never lost before
like
like uh angela came back pretty good but
when she lost to
jean lee oh damn it
i don't wanna butcher i'd rather not try
it yeah but um i'm a big fan of hers
actually when she
when she beat angela angelo was like
broken you know yeah
that [ __ ] hurts how do you how did you
like mentally kind of
move past it because i feel specifically
with you know even in our generation too
um and and the younger generation uh
loss is something that a lot of people
just don't want to deal with a lot
um i had a relative to where
he just couldn't deal with [ __ ] up
like that concept of
failing was so foreign to him right and
what i was trying to tell him in my case
too yeah
because he was trying to use me an
example he was like well you're doing
well i was like yeah but you never saw
how many times i failed yeah like yeah i
failed
so many [ __ ] times like this is this
is a part of the growth process right
but i guess like for fighting i don't
know what it feels like for fighting
because even when i spar sometimes and i
have like the worst days
i feel like [ __ ] like i feel terrible
like it eats me up
all [ __ ] day yeah that's that's
because you're not experienced
that's what happens when you don't
manage your expectations it's like an
emotional rollercoaster because like
[ __ ]
i gotta get this take down damn it i
didn't get the takedown [ __ ] yeah i
gotta get this punch damn it i didn't
get the punch [ __ ] it's over
but when you're a pro you're like
alright cool takedown didn't work go to
something else all right cool the punch
didn't work it wasn't something else but
like to manage
loss it depends on who you're talking to
because
so how you are in sport is how you are
in life right so you go back to like
little league
that little [ __ ] that chief he's
always gonna be a cheater
the little [ __ ] that half-assed
is it he's always gonna be the
half-asser
you know like you are in life how you
are in sport for me it's the opposite
i've been in sport how i've been in life
because i've been through so much in
life that once i started this sport i
was like
dude i've been here before like let
downs or whatever they're not really let
down so just
kind of just what happens and i dealt
with it by just moving on i got another
fight
i booked one right away that's nuts like
i booked one right away i could not
stand it
i was like yo i'm back like could you
not is was it
more like motivating for you to be like
i don't like this loss and i want to
come back and do better no i didn't give
a [ __ ] about the loss
it was um it wasn't the loss like
publicly
or i still don't care like when people
make fun of like for how high ranked i
am
and how high level i am my record
doesn't reflect it and i don't give a
[ __ ]
it's not really the loss that i heard it
was for me is like
i want to show myself i can do better
yeah and you know like i just i can do
better
i can do better and how better to show
yourself you can do better than doing it
again
were you were you uh uh born in vietnam
i was born in vietnam
when did you come here 95. oh okay
how old were you then i was seven
oh [ __ ] so you came here pretty later on
then yeah yeah i remember vietnam and my
entire family came with me so
we have like tons of generations in the
family like we have a big family oh
really
yeah like yeah like my mom and dad
obviously and my sisters were all
went through the vietnam war and then we
have my middle sisters who went through
like
the aftermath of the vietnam war and
then we have me who was like
coming to america damn that's all in one
family that's [ __ ] nuts yeah so
nobody understood each other nobody gave
a [ __ ] what each other felt like because
everybody had different life experiences
you know huh it was hard like
and then i go to i go to like my
american school and they have like
feelings and their mom's like hugging
them and like
like if they didn't like their lunch
they would throw it away and i was like
you can throw your food away you don't
think i'm like looking up like my mom's
somebody's watching me i gotta eat all
this [ __ ] even if it's spoiled i'll
throw it up later
yeah but and then i go home and i tell
them like hey like
my friends aren't getting hit and
they're not like kneeling on rocks like
and my family like all right cool yeah
yeah yeah yeah you want to go over there
yeah go ahead isn't that crazy though
like uh
i think that's the the how how insane
everybody's life experiences can be so
different in this country yeah
and that's where you know i i talk about
this um
where i had a conversation with somebody
about asking me about masks right
and they were asking about this
comparison to
how it is in asia and they go well in
asia people wear masks right i was like
well
for me anyways this is how i see it this
is not i didn't read this anywhere or
i'm not coming from a scientific
standpoint this is my perspective in my
life
um because i have traveled across asia
and i've seen everything um
this country's basis of what nationalism
is is
what what people believe in national
pride in the united states is going to
be different from
the person next to me to the person down
the street in asia it's a little more
cohesive i'm not saying everybody in
india has the same idea
idea but their identity as a nation is
very very similar
like for me me as a asian american kid
that grew up in sacramento in california
my idea of what an american is doesn't
really have a face
right it's somebody who wants to pursue
their life here and whatever happiness
and whatever dream that they want yeah
but there's somebody out in the south
that's going to be like i agree with
that too but it's only for white people
yeah so this country's identity is so
it's so scattered well it's a it's a
good and a bad you know it's
it's scattered because it's not really
an indigenous country it's
it's it's of everybody coming here and
everybody has different views and
different experiences you know
it was told different stories by their
mom and their grandma and like is
treated differently you know so it's
hard to
compare america to anywhere else and
also america sees a nation as
borders americans don't travel as much
as they should
culture in europe culture and asia
you're all over the place people
identify themselves with culture
so like in asia if you're vietnamese you
go to thailand you know you're
vietnamese because
you you have different tastes and food
you talk a little different whatever
but you don't see it as like i don't
know america just kind of
sets themselves apart so much and they
take pride in setting themselves apart
and i think that is a uh weakness of
ours is not really something to be
prideful of i think we need to
see the rest of the world more to be
able to understand ourselves i mean it's
hard too for people here just because
i think we we can even go further back
of how this country was started
it's kind of yeah to have like you know
like definitive pride but like pride in
which part of the nation fighting with
your
history pride from what house like you
know so it's it's
it's crazy but like the whole mass thing
it's quite [ __ ]
simple okay oh for sure it's quite
[ __ ] simple in asia
people wear it when they're sick when
they have a cold they wear it you know
so i don't get you sick yeah it's like
being mad if somebody asks you to put a
condom on
yeah i mean like it's for your safety
you get mad if he doesn't put a condom
on so i'm mad you're not putting on a
mask
yeah it's literally the same exact thing
and uh they just don't like that it's
just a huge cultural difference too
because i feel like in asia people tend
to be
a little more concerned about their
other people right so like over here
like i said we always have to take it
back to history and kind of what this
country was founded on yeah in the
united states
people came here because they were
fleeing from something else yeah you
know i mean
you won't talk about refugees this is a
refugee country you know i mean like
people
bounced away and they wanted to start
their own rules and everything else yeah
and because this country is kind of
based on this idea of mutiny
yeah that's how every everybody's scared
that their whole their rights are going
to be taken away from a mass which is so
odd
the issue is like every few
centuries certain some certain people
just want to just up and decide you know
what
that's enough of refuge people coming in
we're gonna just
pee around this country and that's it
this is america now now we have to set
new rules
like you can't just decide all of a
sudden this is gonna be
like yours yeah it's an ever like
flowing this is what the country's about
it's like a flow of like people coming
in and out or people
coming here to flee like you said you
know who are you to say
okay you are the generation it just set
this america like set this country and
block everybody else out yeah
that's a crazy thing to me um i guess
because i'm immigrant so my um
my perspective it's it's different but i
love america like like you said
everybody has different pride like i
love the american
dream you know like and that's what i
had yeah
you know what i mean so i came here in
order to
build my life so that i can go and do
what i do in vietnam now
how did you how did your uh your family
come here was it
was it so my sister came first by boat
okay
um and then she brought us over by plane
okay
yeah so that's kind of nuts like i
always hear like some
some people's stories of how they came
into this country and it's always
different right specifically from
vietnam because of the war
yeah like there are some people who came
here through sponsorship some people
came through adoption
yeah some other people came here because
they [ __ ]
had a kid with a gi out over there they
brought them over too
any means necessary is the only common
factor yeah any means necessary
was it was it hard for you to kind of
adjust to
living here like in the united states
when you were set i mean because i mean
culturally like it
hell yeah but it's way easier than if an
american was to go to a third world
country and it just
yeah yeah it's nicer yeah yeah i had to
adjust to like people being ignorant to
my culture
and stuff but i never had complaints
because not nothing is easy
when you're transitioning and i was just
lucky enough to transition in a place
that was
safer and and we had more like a
place that was safer for me than where i
came from isn't that still doesn't
does it bother you sometimes when you
hear a lot of people complain about the
situation that they're in
because i think for me i have sometimes
i don't want to say i guess because i
scrutinize more asian americans i'm
asian american right
so like when i hear these kids who have
parents who are first generation
immigrants right because i immigrated
here too i'm from korea and then
i think because we grew up with a lot of
nothing so when even when i have
something right now
yeah i'm very grateful for it yeah so
sometimes it's hard for me to listen
like when you said that it's like you
hear these kids they go i don't want to
eat this for lunch and you're like [ __ ]
you got a choice like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is like this that's nuts
yeah
but i'm not really bothered by it i just
feel bad for them
you know i'm just like because
whenever i tell my story it's kind of
it's crazy like
i'm like a i come from like a ball of a
bunch of
underprivileged things you know yeah
yeah yeah that's really my life
but now i'm praised for it what i used
to be ashamed of
i used to hate being asian because fob
wasn't cute and like
i used to oh all kinds of stuff and
we'll get into it now but
um i used to be ashamed of where i come
from
and now and people used to make fun of
it and now people praise me
for like b how are you so strong b wow
your story is incredible
people only praise you once you get
through it so it's like who gives a [ __ ]
like that's how i'm going to teach my
kid like
you better start praising yourself now
for the mishaps like
for the for everything you're going
through for the hole in your shirt you
know
because like the fake praise is going to
come later like
you need to start praising yourself now
yeah i think that's why people sometimes
have an
issue with uh it was hard for me to
understand maybe because i'm i have a
very just kind of lacks approach about a
lot of things
except for certain things that pissed me
off but i was like
yeah but i mean but i always do it with
the sense of like comedy right because i
always have to make somebody
yeah you're brilliant at it you're good
so at the end of the day like when
people ask like man
you must be pissed a lot it's like no
actually once i say it and i make a joke
i move on with my life
like i'm not sitting here dwelling on
something unless i'm trying to make a
positive change for it
right no but that's how people that's
how you get people to
hear it yeah because people just respond
better to being confronted like some
people have to be [ __ ] confronted you
know
just because you have a sense of peace
for yourself
doesn't mean that when you want change
in others like peace might not work you
might have to cuss them all the [ __ ] out
oh for sure like i always i'm pretty
sure you guys know out there too
you always know one [ __ ] that
miles off too much and the first thing
that pops in your head is you've never
been stocked in the facebook
you have never been stalked in the face
because if you got stalked in the face
you wouldn't be mouthing off like that
yeah you know and
that's lo and behold specifically when i
went to college there was a i mean this
is a very
weird story but when i went to number
one i didn't want to go to
uc riverside i went to uc riverside
because my dad told me he was going to
disown me if i didn't go to university
even though it was a [ __ ] university at
the time so i went to riverside and
i i didn't live anything outside of my
bubble
it was just the homies that i was around
i was a geeky little kid that just
happened to grow up around bad people
because
i grew up with them as kids they just
went a different route and i just hung
around them
so when i went to riverside i i wasn't
used to being around different people
right specifically people that weren't
of my socioeconomic status
and i never really saw bullying the only
time i saw bullying really
was when it was a thug robbing somebody
you know what i mean which to me is not
bullying that's just
you know you were in the wrong place at
the wrong time yeah you're gonna get
your [ __ ] jacked yeah
but i remember for the first time where
i i saw this it was this asian kid
and it was at it was at the dorm that i
was in and there was an asian kid
getting punked
by these two white kids um that went to
the same school high school as them
before
and so his bullies essentially followed
him followed him to the same [ __ ]
college
and so i wasn't used to seeing this [ __ ]
but i remember i got so
angry yeah not even at those two white
guys not the asian kid
yeah so literally as this is happening
mind you i'm a geeky fat asian boy but i
grew up in a very bad area yeah and
bullying wasn't something that i really
took akin to i was still six foot one a
[ __ ] huge kid yeah yeah so this kid
is getting punked and i remember
i literally walked up and i went to this
white guy and i was like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
yeah right he's like oh i'm just having
fun and i literally slapped in
mid-sentence and i was like
still fun yeah what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do about it and this dude was like
oh what the [ __ ] we're just joking
around i told him to get the [ __ ] away
because i [ __ ] him up
yeah i think like it kind of it was a
little weird that the bully got
confronted like that
yeah look at this asian kid and i got so
mad at them almost like
the [ __ ] are you doing i was like why
are you letting them talk to you like
that i was like you don't got to take
that [ __ ]
the kid just stood there quiet and i
felt you know when i reflect on it now i
felt bad because i
he didn't that kid didn't need that but
i got really disappointed that maybe he
did
yeah and i'm like maybe he did and look
at guys like that right and i'm like
those guys never got socked before they
never had a bully come
a kid who they typically thought they
could bully stand up to them yeah almost
telling them was like if you stood up to
them
they wouldn't have done [ __ ] yeah you
know yeah i remember i went to american
high for a little bit
and then i went over to james logan
because we were just like jumping around
trying to use different addresses
to get better schools but um anyway i
was at james logan
and um these two these twins
damn it i forgot your names but you know
who you are hopefully
you know you're you're a big asian name
so hopefully these
little shits are listening um they're
probably big shits now but
they followed me from fremont and came
over james logan was trying to confront
me as two twin sisters and i remember it
was a football game and nobody knew me i
was always a loner
i've never needed like friends i was
always a loner
so i was by myself and she they came up
to me and was like just talking [ __ ]
and i just had enough and i literally i
kid you not i've had some great high
school
fight stories but i socked one of them
luckily they were standing like
kind of um next to each other but one
was kind of back
i socked one and my arm went through and
socked the second one
in the same punch and the whole stadium
cheered like everybody was like oh
you're my sister now we [ __ ] love you
yeah yeah
like i was like what did you you really
didn't think something was gonna happen
like they came from american high
to james logan and uh that'd be cool
because i haven't been back to cali so
hopefully some of your listeners like oh
i remember that yeah yeah yeah
it was difficult it's kind of crazy
though when we see uh
people like to test people a lot you
know and um i mentioned this always
before it's like i used to get bullied
out a lot when i was younger but
my biggest objective was because you
know i grew up so poor and then also
like my dad never liked the fact that i
got bullied
he was like well they're going to bully
you just make sure that you're the
hardest person that they're going to be
ever so i i got removed from elementary
school for fighting too much
yeah and then my on paper it looked like
i was a bad kid but it's just that
people always always try to pump me
because i was such a nice kid
but yeah but were you always tall you're
pretty tall i was i was a big kid but i
was i was always nice
and so the problem with that is that
people take your kindness and they take
it as
and so this kid with thick little
glasses little
little kid little anime kid and then but
they also didn't know i grew up in a
very bad neighborhood
if i wasn't tough i would get my [ __ ]
jacked every [ __ ] day
so it's like the school that i went to
wasn't that bad compared to where i was
all the time so
when i would go to school like i
remember when i transferred schools
um to this other elementary school
within the first week these kids tried
to jump me
and then they found out really quick how
difficult it was going to be
yeah so they were like oh this big kid
he's [ __ ] angry yeah because i
remember this kid came up to me and he
was
it was him it was it was this really
weird group it was like this one
white boy with these two mexican dudes
and they tried to punk me
and i was like what nine or nine or
something at the time
and i remember this kid he had a
basketball
and then he was like he tried to chuck
it at me and i grabbed basketball
it doesn't really hurt and then he kind
of chucked it at me and i was like what
the [ __ ] and i kind of let it go
i was like whatever and i started
walking home and as i'm walking home
i was doing taekwondo at the time as a
little kid but this kid tried to run up
and tackle me and i just
back straight kicked him right into the
[ __ ] gut and i wasn't bad at tackling
when i was a kid i was good and so i
literally back straight kicked him in
the gut and he collapsed and he was
gasping for [ __ ] air
and i just turned around and these kids
were like oh yo we're just [ __ ]
joking around
and i got so [ __ ] mad and i had a
really bad temper as a kid i just
started stomping this kid's face in on
the floor
and they just never [ __ ] with me again
it was like
that's what you got to do sometimes and
it's like and i wonder too now it's like
and you know obviously it wasn't a great
neighborhood so it's like these are the
type of things that we had to do growing
up but that's why i worry about kids
these days it's like
sometimes when people tell me stories
and i'm in a big group i'm really good
at reading
the room okay because sometimes i'm like
a little too tough
so like i'll read the room and they're
like tell stories about their kids or
their niece and nephews or something or
their old childhood and i'm like what's
in my head i'm like what's the problem
with that like you know and they're like
oh
oh my god they fought like they hit him
and i'm like yo we used to get stomped
and we're
fine like actually i'm great you know
like sometimes in interviews
like they're like b how do you how are
you so tough and so brave so i'm like
sometimes i want to say because my
dad used to beat the [ __ ] out of me
because we used to like you know
we used to just learn how to live life
like i worry about kids these days yeah
i mean it's i mean there's definitely
different ways to go about it and i
always tell people
when it comes to like immigrant parents
yeah when you're when you're kind of
struggling with the day-to-day
yeah you're trying to [ __ ] make ends
meet you have children you have all
these problems
yeah and you expect some of these
immigrant parents to sit down and be
like
hey little b this is what you got to do
yeah sometimes they don't got [ __ ]
time for that [ __ ]
they're emotionally exhausted they're
financially exhausted
sometimes the marriage for a lot of
these immigrant families they stay
together because they want to keep the
family unit together because it's better
for the children
it's better for them if they split up
they don't speak english they don't know
how to start their life without them
yeah
so a lot of the times when my parents
would hit me it wasn't because
they weren't smart enough to sit down
and talk to me they didn't have the time
yeah it's like listen
i'm gonna beat your ass real quick cause
i gotta get to work i gotta work 20
hours today yeah so i'm gonna [ __ ] you
up real fast
so you know how serious i am and then
when when i have time i'll come and talk
to you about it yeah
so obviously now that we we have a lot
more time we have more money
yeah most likely i'm probably not going
to beat the [ __ ] out of my kids
yeah of course you know it doesn't have
to be that i mean
um they just didn't know any better but
i mean for me when my goddaughter falls
i'm like you all right
yeah like i'm not running at you crying
you know i'm like yo you good
yeah like do you want to go home and you
want to keep playing and she'll tell me
she'll make a decision
whether she wants to go home or keep
playing and it's her decision and that's
just you know it's not
you just deal with them how how you know
life is going to deal with them you know
yeah because i don't think i would ever
trade some of my upbringing
now because i think like it really
helped solidify men
i mean i'm not saying it works for
everybody i think i i was just very
fortunate enough that i i was able to
make things a lot
funnier in my head than it actually was
because we talk about this too and i
talk about this with comedy a lot
because
some some people have a trouble with
like selective moralism what i mean by
that is that yeah
poverty getting my ass beat getting
jumped being robbed these are all not
funny things yeah
comedy allows it to be funny so when you
take a moral high ground on comedy and
you can laugh at my pain from being poor
what's the [ __ ] difference if i laugh
about i don't know you being ugly
but you're like you can't judge the way
that i look like you being
what is it when they receive like a
trust fund baby yeah or some [ __ ] right
it's like it is what it is you know but
a lot of art
yeah it's art and and art comes from you
know experiences
so a lot of this stuff really molds how
how we are today and uh
yeah the only thing i would change is
generational wealth yeah and
systemically and that's why everybody's
working towards it right now because if
you think about it me and my sisters
were all still tough
but it's just so tough on their kids but
their kids are gonna they're buying cars
for the kids when they turn 16 they're
gonna have a car
they have a better chance at life you
know like generational wealth and like
just a better jump at life i would not
take anything back
in my upbringing except for how hard we
had to work for
simple things that life should have just
things like food and stuff like that
like i don't think those are things you
need to work for
did you ever did you ever uh get bullied
when you were younger
yeah but i got bullied by
i was just challenged constantly when i
was younger
i was bullied by my family first
constantly challenged and then i grew up
in the hood so i was fighting like
six feet tall like mixed chicks you know
like i was like fighting like
big chicks and like groups of chicks and
like
yeah you know it's not the best
upbringing but
it just showed me how tough i was you
know
um who fights for you just like walking
around they just [ __ ] try to [ __ ] you
up now most of the time you're a little
asian girl with
knockers in your hair and and you're in
a black neighborhood they're like
who the hell are you i'm like well we go
to the same store these are just the
rubber bands they had store
yeah which you beat me up for yeah you
know
and like yeah i like the you know like i
you know it was like
they they were just upset
that they they thought i was like
appropriating culture but i was just
in the same culture as them at the time
you know yeah um but anyway it was just
a lot of that but it was
obviously now that we're adults we know
it's a lot of projection of everybody
else's feelings but
um it's hard and it's so weird when we
try to have that conversation and you
know
obviously they can only see it from an
outside perspective but it's like yo i'm
not from this country i don't know these
rules yet
i mean like i don't know what i don't
know what appropriating is it's just
it's in the store right and america is
just a big old country of
cultural appropriation yeah but i i
i just think for me it's like
i feel bad for people who who
don't know a lot of things because it
just means you didn't get to go to the
filipino [ __ ] bomb ass house parties
i went to
you didn't get to go to the dope ass
black barbecues i got to go to
you didn't get to like i don't know just
i experienced a lot of different people
in oakland
in the bay area and that's why i people
think i say the right thing so i'm woke
or i know it's just i was lucky enough
to experience it
now people think it's a chore like oh i
gotta research to make sure i don't say
anything offensive
no just go kick it with people yeah like
go learn go have fun like
you know it's it's harder for people
because you and i grew up in
uh the bay area like norcal right so
norcal
it's it's and i what a lot of people
don't understand that norcal is very
integrated
yeah socal has a lot of cultures but
they're not integrated yeah there's
a lot of space yeah they just kind of
kick it with themselves yeah there's a
space
when you allow people to be in their
comfort zone they will be but in the bay
you're up on each other
all over the place all over the place in
the bay the the
the phrase like hood or ghetto is not
is not directed towards black people
yeah it's all cultures it's just
whatever
like neighborhood you came from and i
understood that from a young age
and even like my mom like she's old
asian lady
that cooks cook makes cookies and cooks
for everybody and she never
discriminated
although some of my friends were
questionable she never discriminated
against them you know
yeah because everybody's just kind of
living that same life
and i i like for example i didn't
realize
technically how poor i was yeah until i
went to a place where people had money
yeah because in your small world
everybody doesn't have much money yeah
y'all just kind of living and doing your
own thing that's the misconception i'm
sick and tired of
i'm kind of like low-key upset at crazy
rich asians because i'm like yo
all my friends were like yo i watched
crazy rich asians like i understand you
more now i'm like no you don't yeah
i ain't rich or crazy like i'm a drunk
i'm a jungle asian i'm vietnamese
i don't know i didn't come from
singapore you know what i mean like
this is like a very big misconception a
lot of us are immigrants and came here
with a hundred dollars
to a family of 11. yeah i think it's uh
i mean it's
it's one of those things too like people
didn't understand why i didn't like i
didn't have like a
specific issue with it it's just they
also have to understand i'm not that
asian so i can't relate to it so it was
hard it was just i didn't get it
you know so i mean like like in your
case right you're uh
you're a vietnamese refugee your story
is different you know what i mean
like but i don't judge like i'm but but
the thing is i'm young so the weird
thing that happened with me is
my fam my mom is 70. so there's
nine kids yeah but i am very much
first as a first generation yeah i'm
very much that generation of refuge i
still call i mean i'm technically a
refugee even though i wasn't in the war
yeah because that's how i grew up and
then so but
my age i'm with you guys who are
mostly american right is that what you
identify yeah mostly american but i
never
judged it like at all because it's just
i just had the understanding of people
come from different places being an
immigrant there is a big thing called
imposter syndrome you just don't know
who the [ __ ] you are
where it's supposed to be in every place
every part in your life you feel like
you don't belong there
not in a sense of like hair color what
you look like or whatever but it's like
you didn't really have an identity
especially when you
are young and come to this country
because at home you're not asian enough
yeah you didn't go through that [ __ ]
yeah then you go to school you're not
american enough because you're kind of
weird and
you're tougher than them you know so you
have this like weird
imposter syndrome everywhere you go and
you just gotta like
learn to make your own [ __ ] world and
that's why i
love immigrants now because it's a breed
immigrants are a breed of people people
that were born and not born here but
came here are breed no matter what
country you came from
because we grew up specifically not
fitting in now it's like a whole
[ __ ] gang of like immigrants just
like knowing each other you know
it's it's it's it's how i mean this
generation this next generation is going
to grow up without
a lot of the stuff that we were around
and what we went through like even what
i say too
when it comes to like gang violence and
[ __ ] when we were growing up like gangs
were the [ __ ] like
you wanted to be a part of a gang like
it was like i let you down yeah i was
never
again it was like the cool thing though
you know now i think it's not like being
artsy
uh yeah things are changing things are
better which is great you know so
like even even for something like my
experience like there was no way i was
going to be a thug right but it doesn't
mean it didn't mean i didn't glorify it
though
yeah yeah i just didn't have it in me i
didn't have
that type of upbringing where that was
something that was a viable option but
being around it made me want to be
around it there's a reason why i still
tried to hang out with these guys and
why i didn't do well in school why i
didn't do because i thought
it felt great having these guys empower
me it's almost like i walked around and
i was like these people could try to
[ __ ] with me but yeah you're not
yeah like yeah it was it was it was kind
of
indulgent to be a part of that stuff but
now i'm kind of glad that they don't
have to go through that
yeah but i think it's a balance because
i think everything is a balance right
but i
i think that you really need to
remember your roots because people are
just lost in the sauce out here
like with so much influence social media
and like social media
like you forget who you are and you're
easily malleable like you're easily
molded into
other beings and you see like even
wonderful things that are trending
it's great right but do you even know
what that is
like do you even know what you just
posted do you even know like who you are
yeah and people can argue with me all
day
i've had so many arguments because i'm a
refugee with people they're like i'm
american i'm not mexican
yeah i'm american i'm not asian like yo
no you're asian american you gotta
remember that because if you don't
remember that you won't remember who you
are
even if you were born here yeah you know
what i mean it's like
super important because if you don't
remember who you are you don't know who
you are you're gonna become
anybody they want you to be yeah i think
cultural ties are very important
um like for me i'm pretty adamant that
my kids are gonna learn how to speak
korean
yeah even better than i do it just gives
you a little extra sauce you know what i
mean
because then we're gonna have this like
bland-ass country of everybody being the
same
yeah i think um people are starting to
catch on now that the the concept of
what it is to be an american
isn't this like anglicized like white
thing right it's
i think your american experience is the
the color and the flavor
that you bring yeah so when you when we
talk about this
like i said this is this is an inherent
issue that america has with our own
nationalism we don't have a set
definition
so for me like my definition of being
american is the fact that i am
a korean-american i can have my culture
i can still co-exist in this country
and then we could all share and barter
and trade our stories our lives our food
yeah that's my american experience right
so back in the day when it
like specifically like in the 80s and
the 70s for a lot of these immigrants
it was i need to get rid of my culture
so i can adapt so i don't stick out
now you have the space to revisit you
see all these kids like
researching now and i see all these
stories resurfacing these heroes that
i've known about my whole life
yeah um but resurfacing because of young
people
yeah and it's dope like all these
stories even black american culture
asian american culture i've known for a
long time but it's just good to see like
it in the mainstream you know yeah so i
don't have no fears for the for the uh
for the new generation i think almost
being uncomfortable is our comfort right
that's what we grew up in that kind of
keeps us moving forward it gives us
drive
yeah so that's that's the hard part i
think for me too is when um things go
really well
i actually start feeling a little
uncomfortable yeah i almost want to
sabotage myself sometimes we're
so self-stopped all the time it's like
i'm gonna make things
like my manager used to hate this [ __ ]
all the time like i would do something
really well
it starts popping off and i'm like okay
i'm done and he's like why
yeah i'm like because i did it yeah i
want to do something else
yeah so when when the whole film thing
happens usually when like good things
happen to us they don't last long and
we're taught they don't last long
so when you accomplish something you
want to move on because you you feel
like well this isn't going to last if i
stay here it's going to fail
you know so you just keep keep moving
for me for sure
yeah the grind feels really satisfying
too sometimes it's like this
is it keeps me going like i want to it's
almost like i'm trying to prove somebody
and prove something to somebody
and that somebody is nobody yeah
sometimes i almost like
of course i don't want to lose but
sometimes i love when people talk [ __ ]
and i love that
i'm the better fighter when i chip on my
shoulder you know like something to
prove
so if you praise if if i get praised
that's why i keep real people around my
life i get praised too much i don't know
who i'd be probably somebody i don't
like
yeah you know i think most fighters too
when they don't have that chip on their
shoulder
you could somebody like mike perry
cannot be treated like jon jones
he will not be the person he is jon
jones is kind of used to it because he's
always been that great you know like
that's why i say like like me and angela
lee were opposite humans
yeah you know opposite if i was treated
like angela lee all the time i don't
know
who i'd be like i don't know how
comfortable i'd be yeah same vice versa
you know
so like yeah so it's just it depends
so what are your what is so you're
looking for a fight in october and then
what else can people look forward to oh
man i'm finally finishing up this book i
had a book deal like three years ago
but i kept like re-writing it because
i'm always like oh which perspective is
right
yeah when am i gonna be in the right
place to talk back about these
talk about these things and i'm just
like you know what pandemic pandemic
pandemic perspective is right so you can
expect that coming out
um by 2021 and then i'm starting an
online academy first youtube and then
academy so that people
i'm realizing now especially in pandemic
people don't really have access to gyms
but not just people that are forced to
stay at home there's people in it i have
fans like in india that
they have to go to a shop to find wi-fi
to look my stuff
up oh wow i have fans like that and
those fans that don't have access to
anything those are the ones i'm going to
make this for
yeah that's awesome yeah so they can
train and hopefully have
a shot at a career without having to
travel the world like i did
yeah yeah that's dope well i mean
where can people find you like plug all
your [ __ ] ah
instagram twitter it's killerbmma
and um i don't want to plug my youtube
yeah it's not ready
but yeah just find me on instagram and
twitter killerbmma it's funny people are
like oh
bema i think that's my name i'm like
it's killer b mma
like people think my name is bema people
that don't like
no fighters that's how i know new fans
from old ones i'm like i'm not being
that's [ __ ] hilarious but yeah just
on social media is pretty cool
cool well thanks for coming in thanks
david what was that like six hours
[ __ ] i don't know that was a good
conversation though it's a great
perspective for people who uh who want
to
know about fighting so it's cool yeah
well guys that's wraps up this
episode and we'll see you all next time
peace